《红楼梦》里,薛宝拆身上有一个最大的黑料。便是第27回的低脆停风波。政治4月26,既建花神,重拆奇距,读林黛玉无故缺席。薛宝拆自高分永,前往销销管区交待遇。
阴剑宝玉进了销销管,薛宝拆不便打扰,一个人嫌不归来,路上发生了经典的宝拆铺蝶。
随后追赶胡蝶到了低脆停,无意中听见压换小红,质而在议论假云,话题涉及男女风话。
薛宝拆为了紧急避险,假称自己是来找待遇的,结果小红物以为,自己的谈话被林黛玉全部听了去。
这个情节自红楼梦问事以来,受到无数评论者的争论,其观点大有两极分化之趋势。
谦云在,关于薛宝拆的典型分析问题中提出如下观点。
至于铺蝶那一节,更是一段很美的书情文字,是用以表现薛宝拆的乐趣的。
以后,薛宝拆也只是为了避险,才来了个经常拖巧之际。
如果说薛宝拆有意识的价货与人,这不仅在整部作品中,没有任何思想上和感情上的线索可寻。
从作者的心情上来说,也是难以理解的。
曹雪琴为什么对于一个悲劣监察之图,在揭发他之前,先为他写一段美丽的书情文字来美化他。
立足作者创作心里的角度,得出以上观点,这自然是有道理的。
但这道理却难以服重。
尤其是内具,只是为了避险,更令精之独者文之不爽。
因为事实是,薛宝拆的确把问题转移到了灵代域身上,如果强行遍解,于制学而言并不十分体面。
但千云的遍解中,有一个点是格外职的注意的,那就是,薛宝拆并非有意识的价货与人。
与此相对比的是扎艾林,他在红楼梦眼之,四强红楼梦中就认为,
批语盛赞宝拆即便真解,但是此处,他实在有价货待遇的嫌疑,为待遇捷愿。
相比之下,扎艾林的说法代表了目前的主流观点,
因为相比于,作者怎么会如此写宝拆,这样的感性化理解,独者们更加误实,
更愿意通过实实在在的情节来做出自我判断,这是无可厚非的。
布红君以为,对于低脆停风波这案例,八个字足可概括其内涵,
那便是,甩锅是真,价货是讲。
此论并非是获稀你,采取各达五十大版的折中妥协之道,
而是立足历史辩证的角度,来评判红龙梦中人物行为。
事实上,低脆停风波之所以争论不休,就是因为独者没有采取这种角度。
成如苏联学者一些坑所论,一致半截者独古代希腊悲剧,
天真的以为,古代希腊人的思想感受方式和我们完全一样。
放心,大胆的议论者,而离普斯王的良心折磨和悲剧故事等等。
可是专家们知道,这样做是行不通的。
古人回答的不是我们的问题,而是自己的问题。
此说也可用在低脆停一案。
以今天的视角来看,虚保拆的行为,无疑就是价货。
但在红龙梦的背景年代里,这种价货就得打上一个大大的问号。
最直接的证据就是,红龙梦的批书人只验摘,
对于经知独者一眼看穿的保拆价货,
他却没有提出相同的看法,
更没有批下此类批语,恰恰相反。
他的批语都是在夸占学保拆。
假训本地27回莫总平有记,
迟编细迭偶而试性,停外极致拖敲,
明写保拆非疑,拘据然一,与女夫子。
证文中,保拆故意放众角步,
口中大教待遇的名字,以为经常拖敲之计,
更有耕臣批语写道,归中弱女即便如此之便如此之急。
保拆向小红贴尔,寻问待遇的消息一段,
又有耕臣夹批计道,相极,好傻,妙傻,
厌得不,拍案教绝。
保拆经常拖敲后,小红贴尔性以为针,
假训本又批,针弄英尔,轻便如此,
急于致死已要发酵。
为什么只验摘几户手等批书人,
不折骂学保拆,反而处处称许?
他们难道看不出这是赤裸裸的价货吗?
莫非批书人偏爱学保拆,
尽到了是非不变的地步。
布红军以为,造成这种意向的原因是,
只验摘等批书人是和草血秦生活在同一时代的至亲好友。
同样有封建贵族体验的批书人,
能无限接近书中人的真实感受,
从而给出符合那个时代那个家族的真实批语。
所谓的价货说,脱离了真实的时代背景,
忽略了灵代预的贵族小姐身份,
高估了小红贵儿的奴谱身份,
从而产生获端的错觉。
红楼梦展现的是封建贵族之家的真实生活,
诸葱等级界限更是误用多说的。
小红贵儿暗地里谈论假云,言语涉邪,
过错方乃是小红。
若真说有货端,那也是小红的货端。
类似之案例如,冤枉女无异于冤枉。
压缓冤枉无异中撞破了私旗盘有案的丑事,
货端乃在私旗一方。
孤儿私旗苦苦贵旗说,
我们的性命都在解解身上,只是解解超生要紧。
其后,私旗担心冤枉卸密,
几日愁眉不断影视不敬,
一致我并在床,
直到冤枉前来安慰他,
他哭着肯求冤枉。
你若果然不告诉一个人,
你就是我的亲娘一样,
从此后,我活一日是你给我一日。
我的病好之后,把你立个长生排位,
我天天分香礼拜,保佑你一生扶手双权,
我若死了时便履便狗报答你。
私旗的情况比小红要严重得多,
而且察觉致人乃是同为压缓的冤枉,
尽管如此,
私旗事后也完全不敢采取报复优血的手段,
来针对冤枉,
更不用说所谓的滅口,
此类皆是公斗剧思维,
实不足异博。
意味而处,
临待遇的地位,
远不是冤枉能比的,
平而乃,甲母最宠爱之外孙女,
迎看西三个青孙女,道歉靠后,
小红则是个压缓,
地位差别玄书,
正如家家三小姐碳春所言,
那些小压头子们原始些玩意儿,
喜欢和她说说笑笑,
不喜欢便可以不理她,
便她不好了,
也如同猫儿狗儿抓有了一下子,
可数就数,
数不过时,
也只该叫了管家媳妇们
去说给她则法。
看春此言,
意语到迫封建贵族家庭的森言等级。
压缓不过是劳动工具,
属于猫儿狗儿,
这种等级尊悲的意识形态,
早已融入每个红楼中人的思想里,
不敢有半点愈悦。
孤儿低脆停风波之,
架货性之,买是空中楼格,
因为根本无获可架,
私旗被当场之间,
上起不敢对冤架采取强硬措施,
只能一位贵旧。
小红只是怀疑待遇偷听了去,
他要么祈祷待遇没有听到,
要么也去贵旧待遇饶他一命,
除此再无其他措施可用。
正是基于这一层基本认知,
从贵族之家长大的草雪琴只验摘,
都不会觉得这是架货,
反而夸赞保采机密,
完全将该情节当成一个娱乐节目。
从雪宝拆的角度出发,
他也生活在同样等级森严的贵族世界中,
自然也清楚此举时难产生架货的效果,
至少雪宝拆主观上没有架货的意愿,
这基本是可以断定的。
架货虽是假,甩锅确实针,
保采为了避免尴尬,
将待遇当盾牌使用,
这是无可变薄的客观事实。
而且这种甩锅本身带有撒谎的成分,
与成实熟悉的道德价值观相备,
故而每每遭到读折,口猪比发。
这种道德平派的严重程度,
取决于读折自我制定的道德底线高度。
喜欢保采制读折,可轻松亮解,
不惜保采制读折,则将其扩大为人品问题,
接触文化接受知阅读反馈的必然产物,
倒也无需刻则。
至于保采为何选择待遇当盾牌,
正如诸多前人所说的内班,
出于心理的惯性作用。
保采不叠之前,
本就是要往待遇处要他制原中与众人玩耍,
只因见到保育,先一步进了消消管,
为免待遇多新猜计,才办图抽身回来。
因心理的惯性,
先前作为一念存在,
而与寻找之人物会在脑海中依然流存。
与铺跌的短时间中,
暂时隐墨形成残向,
一旦面临破解需要之计,
最易呼之语出。
成为新首年来的取材对象,
在十分变当而和人情之长。
临待遇备冲当盾牌,
在红龙猛全书中并非偶然现象。
可能是因为临待遇受家母宠爱的特殊地位,
导致他成为打原厂的必备工具。
例如第46回,
冤枉女士觉冤枉偶。
假设义欲强取冤枉,
让秦夫人前去说没。
即将阴差扬错,
平而也被牵扯其中。
王夕奉为了让平而突生,
失去秦夫人的一心,
便假称平而被临待遇叫走了。
原住是这么写的。
秦夫人又问,
还有谁在跟前?
金家的道还有平姑娘。
奉劫而忙道,
你不该拿嘴巴子打她回来,
唯一出门她就逛去了。
回家来连一个人也摸不着她,
她必定也帮着说什么呢。
金家的道,
平姑娘没在跟前,
远远的看着都像是她,
可以不真切,
不过是我白存夺。
奉劫变命人去,
快打了她来,
告诉她我来家了,
太太也在这里,
请她来帮个忙。
风而蒙上来回道,
林姑娘打发人,
下请自,
请了三次次她才去了。
奶奶一进门我就叫她去的。
林姑娘说,
告诉你奶奶,
我反她有事呢?
姐,听了方法,
故意的还说,
天天反她,
有些什么事?
王惜奉和风而主不良人,
一唱一鹤,
若不是我等独者,
占据上帝世久,
几乎也被她们骗了。
在大官员中,
和冤养习人聊天的正式评二。
风而故意说,
评二被林待于叫走,
就是为了造成一种,
原中人并非评二的假象。
从王惜奉风而,
轻车属路的姿态来看,
她们恐怕不是第一次
打着林待于的旗号撒谎了。
只不过这些谎言,
仅仅是为了脱困,
与道德平派而言不胜严重,
故而每每被忽略。
相似的例子还有第58回,
性子音假奉气虚谎。
细子偶官在大官员内烧纸,
严重违反员内制度,
被员内婆子当场摆住。
婆子先向李文王惜奉得汇报,
然后捉拿偶官要去问话,
被假保育撞坚救下。
最终为了让李游更加合理化,
婆子还是把国丢向了待遇。
那婆子听了这话,
忙丢下之前,
培肖央告保育道,
我原不知道,
二爷若回了老太太,
我这老婆子岂不完了,
我如今回奶奶面去,
就说是爷祭神我看错了。
保育道,你也不许再回去了,
我便不说。
婆子道,我已经回了,
叫我来带他,
我怎好不回去的。
也罢,
就说我已经叫到了他,
被林姑娘叫了去了。
保育想了一想,
方点头英雲,
那婆子值得去了。
相比上述王惜奉奉而的案例,
显然此处的黑郭性质更加努力,
因为偶官本身就是林代域的压缓,
偶官稍止违反原内制度,
婆子向上级回话,
我已经叫到了他,
林姑娘叫了去了。
在不明就里的人看来,
就成了林代域世重而焦,
帐着自己受重毫无底线的户毒子。
更加令人侵察的是,
假保育居然点头英雲,
就其原因,
假保育本身就经常懒事。
第61回的玫瑰魯斯戒案,
强小未案,
假保育为了保护压患彩雲,
留武而,
硬是将这件事拦到自己身上,
可见其形式风格。
因此第45回,
大官元施设缺乏资金,
李完带着一种子妹来到奉劫住处,
所要启设资金。
奉劫应付完毕后,探口气说,
这些事再没两个人,
都是保育生出来的。
可见奉劫以拆出,
是假保育给众人出主意,
来找自己要钱。
再如第61回,
判冤决于平而行权之后,
平而来向奉劫回话,
奉劫听说一切罪责都被保育单了,
不免再次砍炭。
奉劫到,
所以如此说,
但保育为人不管亲红草白爱都来事情,
别人在求求他去,
他又割不住人两句好话,
给他个探楼子带上,
什么事他不硬成,
咱们弱性了,
将来弱大事也如此,
如何质人,
还有细细的追求才是。
因此,
上述欧官稍止,
假保育同意婆子的建议,
而不顾对待遇名声的损伤,
其原因乃是心理惯性作用,
觉得这等西松小事不足为虑,
想来待遇也不会计较,
便默认了婆子的做法。
因此上,
虚果拆得低脆停风波,
从系论来大有可谈之于地,
经知读者大可评价自我感受,
评判人物行为,
但若是研究,
便有意识到一部文学作品的情节塑造,
离不开时代背景作为轰脱。
要彻底理解这个情节,
也只有利足这个时代背景,
才有可能得出相对客观准确的答案。
这是每一个红楼研究者,
不可忽略的基本素样。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,
我们下个视频再会。